il mesure 107 mètres de long possède une
structure métallique et relie le centre
bourg de civray touraine à tour et en
enjambant le cher le pont de la
canardière vieux de soixante six ans est
en train de se refaire une beauté
un chantier à 3 millions d'euros pour
remplacer notamment son tablier
métallique qui ne pouvait plus supporter
le passage des poids lourds depuis le 11
janvier les riverains doivent donc
contourner l' ouvrage d'art ferme à la
circulation pour un an le point sur
l'avancée de ce chantier avec romain
delville inauguré le 31 juillet 1955 le
pont de la canardière à civray connais
ces derniers jours ces dernières heures
au dessus du cher et langue est tenu par
des câbles chalus mais sur sa structure
le tablier est démontée jusqu'au début
de la semaine prochaine
au total ce sont 150 tonnes 7 mètres de
structures métalliques qui sont enlevés
aujourd'hui on en enlève un élément de
30 tonnes qui est le porte à faux entre
entre pékin et p2 et cet après midi on
enlèvera la partie centrale qui au
niveau de p2 on souhaite l'enlever
compte tenu des éléments de crue des
événements cru en ce moment on voudrait
éviter éviter le moindre problème dans
le week end
le pont de civray fait partie des treize
ponts prioritaire du conseil
départemental à rénover ou à refaire
celui de schiste et est à refaire et
entre dans le budget pont de 13 millions
sur cinq ans à lui seul il coûte 3
million deux cent mille euros
département un pont ça s'entretient une
route ça s'entretient
et avec des périodes qui peut être plus
ou moins long de 10 30 ans 50 ans
seulement il faut y venir et quelquefois
faire une impasse de plusieurs années
sur l'entretien peut coûter très cher à
la fin donc c'est bien la volonté qu'on
a eu c'est de dire où en sont nos ponts
le diagnostic est en fait et bien notre
plan pluri annuel fixe les travaux
réalisés on le fait de nouvelles poutres
feront leur apparition d'ici le mois de
mai et le pont devrait être praticable
en octobre-novembre le futur ouvrage
sera lui aussi unidirectionnelle en
alternance pour les véhicules motorisés
et pourra accueillir piétons et
cyclistes
quant au pont détruit il s'offre cette
semaine un petit tour dans les airs un
véritable pont volant